we don't anymore nowadays much believe
in luck or what was in earlier ages
known as fortune we would think it
extremely suspicious if someone
explained that they had been sacked but
added that this was simply the result of
bad luck and we would think it equally
strange or perhaps just very arrogant if
someone had said that they'd made many
millions but describe their triumph just
to mere good luck we resist the notion
that luck can play a significant role as
much in our failures as in our successes
Luck presents a substantial offense
against modern ideals of control
strategy and foresight we understand
ourselves to be for better and for worse
the authors of our own destinies modern
civilization itself could be viewed as a
gigantic protest against the role of
chance in human affairs science
insurance medicine and public education
take up arms against luck and of one
enormous battles against it so many in
fact that it's grown devilishly tempting
to believe that we may have vanquished
luck and chance altogether however luck
is a fearsome enemy its territory is
fluid and its power unpredictable and
tempestuous wisdom requires us to accept
that it will never be entirely tamed
within every success however ardent our
own efforts there is sure to be a
substantial degree of luck and more
redemptive lis within every failure
there is sure to be much that cannot be
ascribed just to our own foolishness we
make small mistakes all the time it's
only occasionally that a modest error
turns out to have devastating
consequences there are some people who
already believe too much in life people
who are excessively willing to assign
all the outcomes of their lives just to
chance but they need to hear more about
personal responsibility and the capacity
of individuals to
transform their circumstances if they
work at it but in many ways these
passive actors are ever less common in
the modern world for the rest of us for
most of us those who operate with a
daunting feeling of personal
responsibility who will constantly try
and push themselves to match their
highest expectations and berate
themselves for any failure a referential
belief in luck should be far more than a
historical curiosity a belief in luck
remains a crucial concept to take the
edge of our arrogance and at moments
when fate has turned against us to
temper the violence of our self-hatred
our wisdom display cards explore what it
really means to be wise and how we can
strive to become more enlightened in our
everyday lives be sure to subscribe to
our Channel internal notifications
you